everybody's salaries are funded by the
us taxpayers as the people in our
country are deciding between food or
medicine Senator JD V from Ohio was on
Fox talking to Laura Ingram about a
pause in Ukraine funding and how I don't
know maybe we could do a little
something in America for Americans we
learned this weekend that we are funding
onethird of Ukraine's government that
includes teacher salaries janitor
salaries everybody not just the military
everybody's salaries are funded by the
us taxpayers as the people in our
country are deciding between food or
medicine right now people in Ohio can't
afford food young people can't afford to
buy homes we're paying for their
government you're exactly right we've
got to focus on our own problems and
Laura the thing that is in our best
interest is to get the killing to stop
that's what we should be doing with
American leadership not writing more
blank checks to endless does he go
lecture uh lecture Europe lecture Europe
put his hand out to Europe see how far
again it's not the most riveting clip
it's just true it's just true how about
we deal deal with some of our problems
here as lawyers lying out how about we
deal with problems related to prices of
food and things of that nature but B
inflation has caused you know you print
money money becomes worth less food and
everybody wants more of the money
because it's worth less that's that's
how it Cascades throughout the system
and of course JD is right on that we
don't we just don't know what the high
hell is going on there the point of all
this which will get us to the end of the
show is that positive results will
actually arise when you begin to say no
to the things that you know to be wrong
right Ukraine whatever is going on there
and this desire for the machine to
connect it to our border it's wrong Bud
Light suddenly making a comeback because
they've got enough cash to buy out
people it's kind of wrong blaming Kim
Reynolds be because you really want to
get to santis over something when you
know it's actually Trump who did the
original thing with the IRS it's wrong
and we've got to get through this fog of
lies and if you get through the fog of
Lies then you will find that other good
people will stand up and you will build
better
things